¿estás trabajando a un nivel inferior?
No lo creo y siempre he sido alentado
por algo que dijo Charles Eames.
Dijo que era consciente que trabajaba
dentro de las restricciones,
pero no de hacer compromisos.
La distinción entre una restricción
y un compromiso es, obviamente, muy sutil,
pero es muy central en mi actitud hacia el trabajo.
¿Recuerdan esta experiencia de lectura?
La guía telefónica. Voy a dejar la diapositiva
para que puedan disfrutar de la nostalgia.
Esto es de los primeros ensayos de mediados de los 70
de la tipografía Bell Centennial que diseñé
para las guías telefónicas de EE. UU.,
y fue mi primera experiencia del tipo digital,
y un buen bautizo.
Fue diseñado para la guía telefónica, como dije,
para ser impreso en tamaño minúsculo en papel de periódico
en prensas rotativas de muy alta velocidad
con tinta que era queroseno y negro de humo.
Este no es un ambiente amigable
para un diseñador tipográfico.
El reto para mí era diseñar el tipo
que funcionara lo mejor posible
en estas condiciones de producción muy adversas.
Como ya he dicho, estábamos en la infancia del tipo digital.
Tenía que dibujar cada caracter a mano
en papel cuadriculado
—había cuatro pesos para la Bell Centennial—
píxel por píxel, luego codificarlos línea de trama por línea de trama
para el teclado.
Llevó dos años, pero aprendí un montón.
Estas letras se ven como si hubieran sido mordidas
por un perro o algo así,
pero los píxeles que faltan en las intersecciones
de los trazos o en las bifurcaciones
son el resultado de mi estudio de los efectos
de la tinta propagándose en papel barato
y reaccionando, revisando la fuente en consecuencia.
Estos extraños artefactos están diseñados para compensar
los efectos indeseables de la escala
y el proceso de producción.
Al principio, AT&T había querido
hacer las guías telefónicas en Helvética,
pero como dijo mi amigo Erik Spiekermann
en la película Helvética, si la han visto,
las letras en Helvética fueron diseñadas para ser
lo más similares posible la una a la otra.
Esa no es la receta para la legibilidad en tamaño pequeño.
Se ven muy elegantes en una diapositiva.
Tuve que eliminar la ambigüedad de la forma
de las figuras lo más posible en la Bell Centennial
por el tipo de apertura de las formas arriba, como pueden ver
en la parte inferior de la diapositiva.
Ahora estamos a mediados de los 80,
los primeros días de las fuentes de contorno digital,
la tecnología del vector.
Hubo un problema en ese momento
con el tamaño de las fuentes,
la cantidad de datos que se requieren para encontrar
y almacenar un tipo de letra en la memoria de la computadora.
Se limita el número de fuentes que podrían conseguir
en su sistema de composición tipográfica en un momento dado.
Hice un análisis de los datos,
y encontré que el contorno serif típico
que se ve a la izquierda
necesitaba casi el doble de datos
que la fuente sin serif en medio
por todos los puntos necesarios
para definir los soportes serif elegantemente curvados.
Los números en la parte inferior de la diapositiva, por cierto,
representan la cantidad de datos
necesarios para almacenar cada una de las fuentes.
Así que los sans serif, en el medio,
sin remates, eran mucho más económicos,
81 a 151.
"Ajá", pensé. "Los ingenieros tienen un problema.
Diseñador al rescate".
Hice un tipo serif, se puede ver a la derecha,
sin remates curvos.
Los hice poligonales, sin segmentos de línea recta,
soportes biselados.
Y miren, tan económicos en los datos como una fuente sans serif.
Lo llamamos Charter, a la derecha.
Así que fui donde el jefe de ingeniería
con mis números, y dije con orgullo,
"He resuelto su problema".
"Ah", dijo él. "¿Qué problema?"
Y yo dije: "Bueno, ya sabes, el problema
de la enorme cantidad de información que necesita las fuentes serif".
"Oh", dijo. "Hemos resuelto este problema la semana pasada.
Escribimos una rutina de compactación que reduce
el tamaño de todas las fuentes en un orden de magnitud.
Se pueden tener tantas fuentes en su sistema
como quieras".
"Bueno, gracias por hacérmelo saber", dije.
Frustrado otra vez.
Me quedé con una solución de diseño
para un problema técnico inexistente.
Pero aquí es donde la historia se hace interesante para mí.
No deseché mi diseño
en un ataque de resentimiento.
Lo conservé.
Lo que había comenzado como un ejercicio técnico
se convirtió en un ejercicio estético, de verdad.
En otras palabras, me había llegado a gustar este tipo de letra.
Olvídense de sus orígenes. Denle vuelta.
Me gustó el diseño por sí mismo.
Las formas simplificadas de Charter
le dieron una especie de sencillez
y frugalidad
que me agradaron.
Uds. saben, en tiempos de innovación tecnológica,
los diseñadores quieren ser influenciados
por lo que está en el aire.
Queremos responder. Queremos ser empujados
a explorar algo nuevo.
Así que Charter es una especie de parábola para mí, de verdad.
Al final, no había un vínculo causal fuerte y rápido
entre la tecnología y el diseño de Charter.
Realmente yo había entendido mal la tecnología.
La tecnología hizo sugerir algo para mí,
pero no forzó mi mano,
y creo que esto sucede muy a menudo.
Ya saben, los ingenieros son muy inteligentes,
y a pesar de las frustraciones ocasionales
porque soy menos inteligente,
siempre me ha encantado trabajar con ellos
y aprender de ellos.
A propósito, a mediados de los 90,
comencé a conversar con Microsoft
sobre las fuentes de pantalla.
Hasta ese momento, todas las fuentes de pantalla
habían sido adaptadas de alguna fuente de impresión
existente, por supuesto.
Pero Microsoft previó correctamente
el movimiento, la estampida
de la comunicación electrónica,
a la lectura y la escritura en pantalla
con la salida impresa como especie secundaria
en importancia.
Así que las prioridades se estaban inclinando en ese momento.
Querían un pequeño conjunto básico de fuentes
que no fueran adaptadas, sino diseñadas para la pantalla
para hacer frente a los problemas de la pantalla,
que eran sus pantallas de baja resolución.
Le dije a Microsoft, una tipografía diseñada
para una determinada tecnología
es una tipografía en sí misma obsoleta.
He diseñado demasiados tipos en el pasado
que intentaban mitigar los problemas técnicos.
Gracias a los ingenieros, los problemas técnicos desaparecieron.
Así hice mi tipografía.
Fue solo un recurso provisional.
Microsoft regresó para decir que
los monitores de ordenadores asequibles
con mejores resoluciones
estaban a una década.
Así que pensé, bueno, una década, no está mal,
esto es más que un recurso provisional.
Así que estaba persuadido, estaba convencido,
y nos pusimos a trabajar en lo que se convirtió en Verdana
y Georgia,
por primera vez funcionando no en papel
sino directamente en la pantalla a partir de píxeles.
Para ese entonces, las pantallas eran binarias.
El píxel estaba encendido o estaba apagado.
Aquí pueden ver el contorno de una letra,
la H mayúscula,
que es la línea fina negra, el contorno,
que es como se almacena en la memoria,
superpuesta sobre el mapa de bits,
que es el área gris,
que es como se muestra en la pantalla.
El mapa de bits se rasteriza del contorno.
Aquí, en una H mayúscula, que son todas líneas rectas,
las dos están en sincronización casi perfecta
en la cuadrícula Cartesiana.
No es así con una O.
Esto se parece más a la albañilería que al diseño de tipos,
pero créanme, este es un buen mapa de bits O,
por la sencilla razón de que es simétrico
en ambos ejes X e Y.
En un mapa de bits binarios, en realidad no se puede pedir
más que eso.
A veces hacía, no sé,
tres o cuatro versiones diferentes de una letra difícil
como una A minúscula,
para luego elegir cuál era la mejor.
Bueno, no había mejor,
por lo que el juicio del diseñador
consiste en tratar de decidir
cuál es la menos mala.
¿Es eso un compromiso?
Para mí no, si estás trabajando
en el más alto nivel que la tecnología te lo permite,
aunque ese estándar puede estar
muy por debajo del ideal.
Pueden ver en esta diapositiva
dos fuentes bitmap diferentes.
La "a" en la superior, creo,
es mejor que la "a" en la inferior,
pero aún no es genial.
Pueden tal vez ver mejor el efecto
si se reduce. Bueno, tal vez no.
Así que soy un pragmático, no un idealista,
por necesidad.
Para cierto tipo de temperamento,
hay un cierto tipo de satisfacción
en hacer algo que puede no ser perfecto
pero que todavía se puede hacer a la medida de su capacidad.
Aquí está la H minúscula de la Georgia Itálica.
El mapa de bits se ve irregular y áspero.
Es irregular y áspero.
Pero descubrí, experimentando,
que existe una inclinación óptima
para una itálica en una pantalla
por lo que los trazos se rompen bien
en los límites de los píxeles.
Miren en este ejemplo cómo, áspera como es,
las patas izquierda y derecha
se rompen en el mismo nivel.
Eso es una victoria. Eso es bueno, justo ahí.
Y, por supuesto, en los bajos fondos,
no tienes mucha elección.
Esta es una S, en caso de que se lo pregunten.
Bueno, han pasado 18 años
desde que Verdana y Georgia fueron lanzadas.
Microsoft estaba totalmente en lo cierto,
llevó unos buenos 10 años,
pero las pantallas ahora tienen
una mejor resolución espacial,
y mucho mejor resolución fotométrica
gracias al anti-aliasing y así sucesivamente.
Así que ahora que su misión está cumplida,
¿ha significado la desaparición
de los tipos de pantalla que he diseñado
para pantallas más gruesas en ese entonces?
¿Van a sobrevivir a las pantallas, ahora en desuso
y a la avalancha de nuevas fuentes web
que llegan al mercado?
¿O han establecido su propia
especie de nicho evolutivo
que es independiente de la tecnología?
En otras palabras, ¿se han absorbido
en la corriente tipográfica principal?
No estoy seguro, pero he tenido una buena carrera hasta el momento.
Eh, 18 es una buena edad para cualquier cosa
con las tasas actuales de desgaste,
así que no me quejo.
Gracias
(Aplausos)